just when I was going to do a video on
the revolution that has happened in
Translation dubbing Along Comes a new AI
image technique that blew my mind got
ready to film that and then the new Bard
comes out which I have now tested in a
dozen ways I'm going to try to cover it
all and show you how you can benefit and
I'll also cover how anyone with
expertise in 26 diverse Fields could
contribute to Red teaming what might
become gpt5 but let's start with Bard
where less than 24 hours ago we learn of
Bard extensions it's a bit like chat gbt
plugins but it works specifically for
Youtube Gmail Google Docs Google Drive
Etc but if we cut out some of the hype
what would we actually use this for well
here's one use case that I will be using
it for that I couldn't have done before
the image you can see is a photo I took
while exploring some Roman remains and
where previously Bard could analyze the
image and tell me a bit about mithras
the God shown it couldn't have done this
recommend a YouTube video to learn more
about this figure notice I didn't
specify mithras it deduced just from the
image that this was mithras and then
suggested a video for me if this had
been available while I was out exploring
I would have probably watched that video
while looking through the ruins I must
say I really like the seamlessness of
not having to separately analyze the
image and then go onto YouTube and
search instead it all happens in one
window in one app likewise imagine
seeing a travel image you like and you
want to know about flying there this was
again a photo I took while traveling
recently and I didn't separately ask it
what location is this and how would I
fly there from London instead it was all
one request flight duration and typical
cost from London to location shown it
actually gave me additional information
about the fisherman's Bastion and then
found specific flights using Google
flights with the Airlines and the
typical costs and I can say that the
flight durations and timings are
accurate let me show you one more cool
thing before we get to some of the
anti-hype I asked Bard to search my
Google Drive for the recent smart GPT
Dock and said write a Shakespearean
sonnet to summarize it and you can
almost imagine this happening for the
minutes of a meeting you've recently
attended or anything that might be a
little dry that you want to spice up a
little bit now yes this sonnet doesn't
accurately Follow The Shakespearean
template but it's really not bad look at
this from Humble prompts thou Dost
create such light thy creators AI
explained and Josh with foresight Keen
have harnessed thy power to solve the
Unseen with Chain of Thought research
and reflection Keen thou Dost answer
questions with Precision Keen however we
are back to the problem of
hallucinations if you can't fully rely
on what Bard is saying its use Drops
massively now I have successfully got
Bard to read a lot of my Gmail messages
it can do that and of course some of the
messages I get are comments on my
YouTube channel but this time when I
asked it simply made up feedback that I
hadn't gotten let's be honest you guys
know YouTube do any YouTube comments
sound like any of these three it seems
very rare to me to get a YouTube comment
that is so neutral and polite and calm
of course I quickly checked and no such
a comment didn't exist this was Bard
hallucinating in fact all three were and
I just want to quickly show you it can
sometimes find genuine comments like
this one but the problem is what is the
utility of searching for something like
that if you can't rely on it also
sometimes you have to remind it to do
things that you know it can do for
example here it successfully went
through my Gmail and found my replit
bill but when I asked how much more is
my replit monthly bill than my 11 Labs
bill it said it can't find anything but
then when I prompted again and again it
first found the receipt from 11 labs and
then compared it but it wasn't smooth
and I would say at this point not
terribly useful likewise this image
recognition of Darth Vader was great
even without naming the character it got
it but the figures for gross revenue
were unreliable and yes I did try asking
to adjust for inflation and it still got
it wrong now you might say what about
that button where you can check the
validity of an answer and I have tried
that out a few times it's this Google
button here that says double check
response after all Bard powered by Palm
2 is supposed to be the only language
model to actively admit how confident it
is in its response and while this did
work to flag up that the gross revenue
figure might be inaccurate saying you
should consider researching further it
doesn't normally flag up too much to be
honest here there was just a single
green line for one answer to this
mathematical problem which it got wrong
this by the way is a classic
mathematical question that I have tested
gbc4 on many times and it also normally
gets it wrong but remember that thing
about Bard being super honest when it
doesn't know an answer I would have been
really impressed if this was full of
orange and red saying I'm really not
sure and I even directly prompted Bard
asking this how confident are you in
this response and it said I am very
confident in my response I then pointed
out where it was wrong and it did admit
the error anyway I don't want to be too
harsh I do think these extensions are a
significant Improvement for Bard imagine
you're on holiday and you see a castle
like this in the distance all I had to
do was take a photo and write YouTube
this it realized what the castle was and
gave me YouTube videos for it so if I
was walking along I could watch that
getting hyped about the castle I'm about
to see it goes without saying that of
course I have been following the alpha
missense news but I am still working my
way through the science paper and it
does seem like that it's more of a step
forward than a sea change as the article
in nature points out of course every
step forward is welcome though in the
fight against things like cystic
fibrosis and cancer I'll have more
interesting bits on this in the future
if I can find them but now we move on to
hey gen Avatar 2.0 which I briefly
demoed in the last video and it shocked
a lot of people I wanted to quickly show
you some of its capabilities in other
languages and I think this kind of
technology is not only going to
revolutionize movie dubbing it's also
maybe as soon as next year gonna make us
question all historical footage we see
let's start with Oppenheimer in Spanish
foreign
let's rewrite history and make Kennedy's
famous speech in French
and two more quick ones before we move
on these are the last two languages it
can do here's Liam Neeson in Polish um
[Music]
foreign
Bambino
is
grazia
don't say my start of Florida Boston I
should note that this only works for
translation you can't just get someone
to say anything not without a consent
form that's why I don't think it will be
as early as next year when a politician
in a major election is able to claim
that they lost due to deep fake imagery
I think it'll be very close and I could
see it happening in 2025 but not 2024.
the guard rails are still quite tight
and the technology isn't quite good
enough I'm of course predicting this on
the wonderful metaculous website not
only are they sponsoring the video but
it's actually free to sign up using the
link in the description as I mentioned
in my last video you can see the
aggregated forecasts of hundreds of AI
questions and I think my audience is
going to be better informed than average
so do sign up and start making your own
forecasts I genuinely want our community
to be among the best informed on the
planet in AI progress speaking of which
I think many of you might be genuinely
interested in some of the guests and
topics I've got lined up with one of the
most famous professors who argues that
GPT models can't reason versus the
recent news that GPT 3.5 instruct can
play chess and you may even hear the
result of my game against GPT 3.5 but
now it's time for this the inventive AI
image generation you saw at the start of
the video I'm going to show you not only
how you can create it yourself but also
how you can turn it into a video
hopefully you can see the AI explained
in this image and maybe you like a bit
of movement like this here are some of
the other Generations if you prefer
things to be a little Bolder and can you
spot the letters AGI in this somewhat
quirky video I just love how two of the
characters just eat their way out of the
video randomly there's two quick tools I
want to show you the first one is Fusion
art where you get 25 free credits what
I've been doing is to create bold text
in Adobe Express I download that output
and then click upload black and white
image I've changed it to 16x9 and then
you can basically get creative with the
prompt you can see one of the other
Generations I came up with here then
what I did is I took those images to
Runway gen 2. you can sign up for free
and then you get 45 seconds of
generation you can see here what some
other people have been doing this is
from stealthy the time traveler
this by the way is the free and
unlimited hugging face space that you
can use alternatively and let me just
give you some tips before I move on the
higher up you make the illusion strength
the more you can see the original
illusion in this case that might be the
letters AI explained or in other cases
it might be the background shapes or
spirals but one big benefit of reducing
the illusion strength is that you get
more interesting lifelike images if you
want different outputs you can also
change the prompt of course or if you
want to keep the prompt the same and get
different outputs just click on Advanced
options and just randomly change the
seed and you'll get a different output
if you ever find the resolution a little
low there are three websites where you
can upscale images Linked In the
description and this kind of stuff is
only going to get crazier when it moves
into the world of 3D as you can see here
but if you find testing for Dangerous
capabilities more compelling than
generating AI images how about the open
AI red teaming Network announced less
than 24 hours ago essentially if you are
a domain expert in any of the 26 areas
I'm about to show you you can join up
and get paid and that's even if you can
commit to as little as five to ten hours
in a year honestly if I didn't have a
bit of a conflict of interest with the
channel I would definitely have signed
up to this getting paid to get early
access to what could be GT5 and Red Team
it seems like a sweet deal to me if you
are a subject matter in any of these
areas then do check out the link in the
description at the very least it should
be highly interesting work that's it for
today a lot of diverse topics covered
and a lot more to come do let me know in
the comments if you found any of this
helpful and thank you so much for
watching to the end as always have a
wonderful day